so just tell a little bit about gitlab
story first
that's its kind of central to what I
want to talk about and our history I
think is a big part of that so let's
let's talk a little bit about that so DZ
Demetri who originally wrote gitlab in
2011 was actually from the Ukraine and
the wasted our CEO who you learn about
next tells the story is he had two
problems he had no running water and he
didn't have a tool that he could use to
collaborate with his fellow developers
at his job and he solved the most
important problem first and wrote gitlab
so then then later on an unnamed orange
website CID was in the Netherlands and
Seoul get labs existence and thought wow
an open-source alternative github this
is a really cool idea like there's 300
contributors like why wouldn't we have
the thing that we all use to write code
be a thing that we can all contribute to
this is really smart and he said Dimitri
hey I think I'm gonna start get lab calm
is that cool when Dimitri said it's
open-source what you want and so Sid did
and then again more lore goes that in
about 2013 Dimitri tweeted I wish I
could work on gitlab full-time and Sid
called him and offered him a job and
Dimitri said yes and the story goes that
said went down to the like Western Union
in Amsterdam to wire some money to
Dimitri to get it started and the person
who Western Union said do you know this
person and he said mmm no they said you
didn't meet them on the internet did you
anyway but it worked out it worked out
and then another another huge
contributor contribution came from a
gentleman named Camille who was in
Poland we never heard of him but he
contributed what is now the main runner
forget lab CI which is one of our
foremost products and so from the very
beginning we're kind of this very
distributed nature and you know in 2015
we went to Y Combinator and and now I
say we like I was there I was not there
we had the there was the typical Y
Combinator experience everyone living in
a house together
also a bus the gitlab bus which if you
look has our old logo on it which I
don't know if any of you were around
when get live had that logo but there
was a user at the end of Y comma R that
said that they had nightmares about that
logo though it's really bad UX to have
your logo giving people nightmares so
change that one and then and then we had
our first office Radio Y Combinator says
well you have to have an office in that
office shall be in San Francisco so one
two three three Howard Street San
Francisco was our first office and you
can see the team there that was also our
last office and this is because people
stopped showing up to work at the office
so in the corner there I bet you can bet
which one of these people is the
salesperson
oh I love Hayden great but he was
driving in from Alameda and he decided
to stop driving in from Alameda because
that's crazy commute and oddly enough
work kept getting done right and today
we've grown to where I have 1200
co-workers at gitlab and they're in 65
different countries and we still have
exactly zero offices and yes exactly
and I'm really proud of this fact like I
love telling people about having
colleagues all over the world we have a
map this map is on our website which
shows you where everyone is so it's all
six occupied continents there's nobody
on America and and like I said all over
the world when we added people in
Greenland I noticed because it's like
they are in Iceland they popped up and
and you see it there and I do mean
everywhere I have two colleagues on the
islands here in Hawaii and although I
don't think there's anyone in Alaska yet
so Hawaii you beat you beat Alaska to
the punch on this money
and so just to give yourself a little
that's kind of the background in the
history of get lab and I'm just
wondering like how many people have
heard of get lab before today awesome
good fantastic
why Brendan O'Leary I'm a senior
developer evangelist forget lab and I'm
not going to talk a lot about get lab
the software today but talk a lot more
about get lab the company because as
much as I believe in the product I was a
kid lab user before I was a kid lab er
I'm more interested in the impact that
we can have on the way people work
together with this this distributed all
remote model and so that's why I'm
making the case for what I'm calling two
asynchronous Enterprise and why is that
well technology excellence is clearly
the new operational accident excellence
in business and the few tech world's
tech hubs that exist in the world are
really not sustainable as the only
source of talent but it's also massively
complex the scale outside of those hubs
unless you have a map massive capital
investment right like so how has gitlab
made this happen without either of those
and I think the answer is a very simple
one and and that answer is trust but I'm
gonna I'm gonna define that a lot more
as we go through it but first what's the
situation again I think you know eight
years ago maybe nine years ago Marc
Andreessen said that software is eating
the world I would say it's eating the
world
more recently still Marc Andreessen
talked about cycle time compression
being the most underrated underestimated
force and determining winners and losers
in tech and competitiveness of today's
businesses depend on how fast they can
have their teams deliver code and which
is to say how fast can they deliver
value to their customers so accelerating
the rate of innovation in all industries
has increased the competitiveness or
those industries and compute increase
the competitiveness for talent and and
leaders are slowly coming around to see
this to be true
and traditional tech hubs like in
Silicon Valley or in San Francisco or
New York are thought of as the center of
these types of revolutions and its
really it is still true to some degree
but this latest data from indeed shows
us that the dominance is waning if you
look at the data over time which I
haven't graphed here you can see that
the dominance of these areas is starting
to wane and companies are required to
seek talent outside of your traditional
tech hubs and I think remote is part of
that solution so being remote right
that's what we believe in a good lab we
are a hundred percent remote we don't
have an office that's part of the
solution but I think and some folks will
say distributor workforce I think
there's a lot more to it than that and
that's what I want to talk about so just
as important is working asynchronously
right so sometimes you'll find a company
that may have remote workers but talks a
lot about the time zones and really that
doesn't get you the full benefit of
remote because you want to be able to
work asynchronous together and working
across those time zones allow you to
then have a lot more cultural diversity
and ideas and new perspectives and
includes different ways of working
together right there's folks of us that
will stand up on stage and talk to a
group of 200 people and folks I don't
want to do that right lay those we need
all of those viewpoints and different
ways of working together to be
successful and I think all those things
are what have enabled our kind of
unprecedented growth and then also I
like to caveat it with even though it
seems like we have it figured out it's
definitely a journey for us as well and
it's one that given our values you can
watch and we'll talk about that in a
second
and so I think more boldly than just you
know let's work asynchronously I think
that remote work is the future of work
and I thought I was the first one to say
no I didn't think I was the first one to
say it but I noticed when I was flying
over here
I rewatched the Steve Jobs movie with
Michael Fassbender as Steve Jobs
certainly seem that Michael Fassbender
Aaron Sorkin only a few people okay
an interesting portrayal of Steve Jobs
and its opens with a News interview of
arthur c clarke in 1974 and he says you
know they're in a room with a massive
room sized computer and there's a
reporter and his young son and arthur
c-- clark says well when he's in 2001
when he's grown up we'll be able to live
anywhere and well you won't have to be
worked stuck in cities we'll still be
able to interact with each other through
computers and so that's kind of a bulk
prediction in 74 and makes me feel like
i'm a little late to the game but this
is not without its complications right
so there's a lot of challenges that come
in in scaling a business to this side
and you know there's cultural
differences there's countries and you
can talk to our legal department about
how fun that is and there's time zones
right sometimes those are the really
hard thing time zones are so hard
because asynchronous work is hard right
coordination with each other actually
takes longer than asynchronous work so
the real question is but will it scale
which is the classs classic software
question right how does one scale a
distributed workforce without this
capital investment because people don't
have that kind of cash line around
well there's gate lab business also not
the only business to have looked at this
so Basecamp is another company focused
on remote and they have an interesting
thing in their handbook both base camp
and get lab have our handbooks published
publicly I can't remember what there's a
license that ours is actually Creative
Commons licensed and they have a great
statement in there that in order to work
this way there's as much to unlearn as
there is to learn and there's other
companies that have done this as well
automatic the company behind WordPress
envision these folks are embracing
remote but there's a lot of things that
you have to learn in order to make that
work
a more direct way that we put it and
something that we always default to is
our mission that everyone can contribute
and everyone really means everyone you
don't have to be in the same place and
once you don't have that constraint of
place it opens up the world in in ways
that you wouldn't think otherwise
out that's constraint of place our our
core team is right in our slack and
that's on our zoom calls and just the
way we work working with the wider
community with the open source community
becomes a lot more natural because
that's how open source works together
have a very clearly articulated set of
values that we really stick to and when
I first read about get lab again I
admitted get live user and I kind of
thought okay this handbook it's a pretty
good marketing come to find out it's
actually like 4,000 pages long and it is
exactly how we operate the business like
if you want to figure out how our
finance people calculate every metric in
the company it's there
because that's that's the only source of
truth that exists and so the same is
true of our values and we talk about
them all the time so that's
collaboration results efficiency
diversity inclusion iteration and
transparency I want to talk about our
each of these enable us to scale this
this asynchronous enterprise so this
graph will see again right iteration is
a huge thing that we talked about there
the ability to take small steps and
constantly adjust scope to make the
smallest step possible allows you to
kind of skate to where the puck is going
to be to give a hockey analogy which
works really well in Hawaiian crowd but
but that's what it is right you reduces
the need for coordination because the
steps are a lot smaller the decisions
you're making the changes you're making
are a lot smaller and how we do that is
we focus on something we call the
minimum viable change so you hear a lot
of folks talk about the MVP and Minimum
Viable Product we break it down further
to say the minimum only valuable feature
and they break that down even further to
say the minimally valuable change this
is the labels really fast iteration
because once you're focused on that you
say well if this is change is
objectively better than it is today
ship it so talk a lot about who's
directly responsible for a decision
right so we have not a lot of command
and control and not allowed to run
something up managers and then down
another set of managers someone is the
DRI for making a decision and they're
going to make that decision and
especially going to make that decision
if it's a two-way door decision so if
it's decision that's easily changed then
making that decision now is a lot better
than waiting or someone on the other
side of the globe to wake up to see if
they agree with your decision
and then we open merge request so we
manage the company through our handbook
it's in get we make merge requests to it
we call other people call them pull
requests but you're requesting to get
merged that's a different story but
anyway we call merge requests it's
already pulled no sorry I'm sorry I'm
off topic I'm off topic anyway but
that's how we can collaborate async a
synchronous late because when we want to
change something that's not a PowerPoint
that then has to get approved and
thought about and those things we're
actually changing how we're doing
business through merge requests and the
second is transparency so we're gonna
record everything by default and we have
to do this because we don't have the
time to afford to train people in
meetings we've said this every year and
it's been true every year so I started
in October of 2017 and I was about 150
hundred and sixtieth and now there's
1200 of us in 2020 so the thing we've
said at the beginning every year which
sounded crazy is at the end of this year
there'll be more people who have been
here for less than a year than the
entire rest of the company right now
and so that's massively a massive change
and without writing everything down and
recording by default you just wouldn't
scale and and those are things that a
lot of companies talk about wanting to
do I hope I should write down decisions
more often right oh we should be more
transparent about how we're making those
decisions well when you are asynchronous
and when you are all remote you don't
have the luxury to not do that and the
other thing is then the receiver can
move a lot faster have the best most
accurate most recent version of the
information and get the message from the
most reliable source
and that's where part of the talk for
Jay s cough come up with came I came up
with the title because it looks sounds
familiar right
you want to have the receiver receive
the information when they're ready when
it's done and when it's were most
reliable right so just like we'd want to
you know have our functions be
asynchronous that's the same kind of the
same thing we do but with our
communication and also efficiency so
this is another big key to what we focus
on so writing down down promises making
sure that they're measurable goals
having a bias for action so I talked a
little bit about this but yes you should
have a thoughtful decision process but
she should make the decision and instead
of being fearful about making mistakes
make the decision make the mistake and
learn from
and then again responsibility over
rigidity we talked about this a little
bit we want to give people a
responsibility to make the decision and
then hold them accountable for that
right the results right that's one of
our values is how we're going to be
accountable and we do that by hiring
people that are that want that
responsibility and it works out a lot
better than a lot of rules and approval
processes to manage people with
so talked a little bit about the
handbook but that's where our writing
down promises really start so it is the
single source of truth the story I tell
about that typically is so the long
story you will have met me after this
because I'm gonna tell a story and so we
once a year we get together somewhere in
the world where he was the money we
saved from San Francisco office we get
together and a week after I started we
were going to crete greece right
actually bought a plane ticket for crete
before i started with a company I bought
my Mac because we didn't have an IT
department back then like Monday I was
like how do expenses work
not like $5,000 on my credit okay so
anyway I went to went to Crete and I met
Sid there our CEO who you will remember
is Dutch which is important for the
story
and I'm like Hamid of getting good with
this guy because I love the handbook I
had read the handbook it convinced me to
apply say day it's nice to meet you it's
nice to meet you he's really tall so
it's more like and I said I really like
the handbook I just is amazing but good
now that you're here what's written one
way but we do it the other way
I don't know but I can get back to you
he said I expect you will you can slack
me when you do flash-forward to me in my
hotel room the week after I started to
get lab in Greece like frantically
trying to find something that's wrong in
the handbook or what little I know about
the company but that really instilled in
me the fact that this is how we run the
businesses is our source of truth for
how we're how we operate together
and then the other thing I always say to
people is we communicate more about how
we communicate with each other than any
other company I've ever worked for right
so we have a huge communication
guidelines it's again handbook gets down
there oh one everything's in draft right
there's nothing there's no final version
of everything
there's no proposals everything's always
in draft and always subject to be
changed
next everything starts with that merge
request so we talked about how the the
merge request that makes it really
obvious what exactly you want to change
is proposed and transparent for everyone
to see
we use public channels so obviously we
do also use a lot of slack but we're
very focused on public channels so that
if you're talking about something you
need to bring someone else in
it's really quick to do that it's not a
group DM which is like the worst UX ever
if anyone to hear works for slack anyway
um we we say thanks so we also have a
public thanks channel where we're very
intentional about thanking people
because there is no you know slap on the
back in the office or high-five and then
we have this very horrible term we're
using very specific but Sid loves it so
you know so we call Missy foo and so
it's mutually exclusive collectively
exhausted few words ubiquitous language
so that we can communicate more simply
but what it is is you know words mean
something and we need to all have a
mutual understanding of those words so
when we say in finance when we say a a R
we know what that means
ARR we know what that means or if in
engineering we know we say you know what
is a senior engineer when it comes to
defining everything you can find a
definition for it on the handbook and
it's critical and we don't we try really
hard not to have terms overlap any and
all those things really add up to trust
right so this is about trusting each
other and kind of having a common ground
where a trust can start
and building that trust again is not not
easy right it's not just you write it
down and it's done as much as you'd want
it to be you have to actually also
invest in individual relationships and
invest in group work relationships and
so we're just as intentional about
informal communication as we are about
formal communication so we have video
calls a lot of zooms happening we have
virtual coffee breaks so that you can
actually you're asked to spend some of
your time socializing and talking about
something outside of work or maybe
meeting someone from the other side of
the world and then the time in person is
very important right so we want to focus
that time in person on relationship
building not on work so one there's a
travel stipend if you
I think it's $150 the handbook would
tell you but for every gitlab ER if
you're going somewhere and you're gonna
meet a gate lab team member you get $150
towards your travel for every remember
you're gonna meet so there's 15 people
in Amsterdam and you live in the US any
when I go to Amsterdam didn't get your
flight paid for we also focus a lot on
local meetups so there's a lot of Lok
underscore channels and our slack that
have the different areas where we have
you know concentrations of team members
and then contribute which I talked about
so we went to I've been to Crete Greece
to Cape Town South Africa to New Orleans
and we're going to Prague in March and
this is critical and also not a bunch of
executives doing powerpoints right it's
about forming relationships together
and when you build this trust I think
your employees and your co-workers
aren't the only ones who benefits so I
didn't stage this Aloha call for the
conference although I definitely would
have so but we had an Aloha call you got
to have a Hawaiian shirt Friday somehow
even if you're a mode right yeah exactly
but again it's not just the company that
benefits it's a huge benefit for us as
individuals right so there's a there's a
stat from an academic journal about if
one spouse commutes longer than 45
minutes that couples 40% more likely get
divorced in the end our you know the
remote work allows flexibility and time
for spouses and kids and partners and
and where you need to live and in fact
we write this down of course then our
values there's a term says family first
a family and friends first work second
and I experienced that myself this is an
actual thanks I thanks to said to my
thanks channel so as I mentioned I have
four kids
my fourth I had while I was at gate lab
and the transition coming back was just
amazing I used to commute 45 minutes and
it would be like okay going to work good
luck versus being downstairs it's just
unbelievable to be able to step away and
help for 10 minutes is just
life-changing for for a family or
anybody needs to take care of friends
alone so thank you so much for your time
you can follow me at a Leary crew and
I'll post in the jobs channel too so
look out for that